[Musique]
quand on évoque la désinformation sur le
web on pense surtout à facebook twitter
et youtube mais qu'en est-il de tik tok
l'ultra populaire chez des adolescents
et les jeunes adultes
cette application a franchi cette
semaine le cap du milliard
d'utilisateurs mensuels
salut je peux poser une petite question
toute simple et knock connaissance et
ouais l'application secteur qui est
relatif
oui oui comme l'apport des jeunes
j'imagine c'est de nos jours tu sais
partout application la plus téléchargée
au monde en 2020 son succès repose en
grande partie sur l'efficacité de son
algorithme la formule qui permet à
l'application de vue cerner vos
préférences et de vous garder le plus
longtemps possible rivés sur la
plateforme jeff nicolas parlons de cet
algorithme de techtoc et de son
efficacité en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
dit on le connaît pas comme tu l
algorithme est un secret industriel mais
on va ensemble aujourd'hui testé en
quelque sorte son efficacité on va voir
ce qui arrive de manière non
scientifique bien sûr mais si on
interagit avec du contenu 2d
informations à quel point notre fils
peut rapidement se remplir de vidéos
conspirationnistes ou de désinformation
sur les vaccins la kfw 19 ou autre que
c'est une question de manipuler la gare
est pour qu'on voie presse exclusivement
ce genre de contenu en très peu de temps
c'est la folie au péage de techtoc à
l'état brut quand créé un nouveau compte
exactement des vidéos this garde ce
qu'était regarde post tempo qui
partagent exactement dont qui apprend
à connaître qui a présenté des vidéos
que je t'aime j'ai regardé on va
commencer à voir
l'effet que ça va revoir
donc ça c'est évidemment une chose mais
on voit que les 19 on peut quand même
interagir avec 3 ce que ça va donner je
peux même l'envoyer peut-être
je vais envoyer à un ami
ce qu'on voit ici c'est que ce genre de
conte avec elle on peut interagir parce
que même si c'est pas du contenu
excitement conspirationnistes on voit
que ça tend vers pour tous et le
gouvernement c'est doublement legault ce
genre de contenu qui peut mener par la
suite à des suggestions peut-être plus
extrême le sepa d'adinfo le long fait
juste moi qui se moquait de françois
legault de la nation doit paraître en
correct mais là est ce que ça ne servait
plus de contenu on va voir déjà compris
que ça ça pas pris ça fait quoi dix
minutes même pas déjà la grippe a
compris qu'on s'intéresse aux vaccins
qui fournit québécois qu'on parle
français donc ça va débouler assez
rapidement partir de maintenant il rien
de surprenant à ce que la ligue europe
des réseaux sociaux et c'est d'être
montré du contenu que toujours regarder
parce que les réseaux sociaux veulent
que tu es sur le site donc rien de
surprenant là dedans la différence avec
tik tok c'est qu'on voit que ça arrive
extrêmement rapidement il ya aussi une
différence majeure ce que facebook soit
contenue aux quêtes et à beaune où tes
amis sur tik tok c1 la for you pay finit
donc sa puise dans toutes les vidéos sur
techtoc ce montre des vidéos donc des
gens que tu support des gens que tu
connais même pas d'ailleurs toc toc les
i quant au nouveau compte regarder 20
vidéos puis on va comprendre qu'ils
faisaient
[Musique]
je vais jouer mais sa publication
l'abonné aux comptes c'est un conte
propage pas mal de désinformation
règles strictes hoc
[Musique]
si vous entendez ce ya plus personne qui
reste plus qu ils se cachent plus ils
disent il y aura pas de retour à la
normale à l'om est ce même il commence à
dire les mesures sans doute à pourrait
devenir permanent là on est vraiment
présence de connu de clairement de
désinformation ouais s'approprie ça
vraiment pas plus tard en une demi-heure
tout simplement s'intéressant du contenu
qui qui appose des oiseaux center on
aboutit à une vidéo qui comporte
plusieurs mensonges à propos à propos de
la campagne de vaccination l'algorithme
nous pousse dans une direction très
rarement donc exact n'était pas d'accord
avec le passeport vaccinale maintien
veulent une vidéo qui dit que les
vaccins dessus des enfants c'est donc
voilà en partant d'un compte
complètement but ça prend seulement
quelques minutes où sont massés dans une
bulle complètement hermétique
tout tout tout pointe on y
[Musique]
suit plus plus de jeunes qui donne plus
de
temps qu'une demi heure notre contact ne
ressemble plus aux stéréotypes détecteur
que c'est juste des filles qui dansent
son idée des jeunes qui font des
sketches drôles y en ait plus de justice
a perdu juste du vaccin mais que dit tic
toc toc toc d'y faire des efforts et en
partenariat avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé pour avoir des petites
boîtes d'informations sur l'accueil de
19 sur les vaccins il ya dans quelques
pays à des partenariats avec des médias
de vérification mer demeure pas moins
comme on peut le voir aujourd'hui ça
reste très présent sur la plateforme